I still grind. I love the grind if you're competing on one of my businesses
I'm gonna kick your ass cuz I'm gonna I'll grind you having lived a life. I've lived in
Seeing the other side not being afraid to attack
What was in front of me has made me happy right now
You're being rewarded for being a yes person and in 36 months. You're gonna be fired for being a yes person
What's that believe nation, it's Evan. My one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan
Level talent at something and I want you to find it embrace it and use it to make a difference
Now the believe life series is a different spin where once a week we're looking at topics outside of just pure hardcore
Entrepreneurship. So to help you live your best believe life today. We're gonna look at the mindset of high achievers. Enjoy
So, let's kick it up with rule number one with Mark Cuban grind I'm not mr. Mentor I'm not the one who says
Let's sit down
Tell me how it's going
I'm gonna tell you exactly how I am get off your ass and get out there and sell something. That's right. I
Mean I've never been the okay. I need a mentor
You know a lot of people look for mentors thinking they're gonna tell me the shortcut
Mark you be my mentor, you know the way and they think I'm gonna go
Convey some magics. Here's the dust go go go. It doesn't work. That way. I
Still grind. I love the grind if you're competing on one of my businesses
I'm gonna kick your ass because I'm gonna I'll grind you right that's what being an entrepreneur that an entrepreneur is
You've got to get out there and do the work. So when it comes to how do you learn right?
Because that's the question. How do I learn this stuff? And
Everybody everybody has got to go through that process
Right. I read our I'm in the tech business. I'm in media business the entertainment business
I've got to try to prepare myself for all the Shark Tank businesses. I read three hours plus a day
right well
Everybody else is getting a suntan or even when I'm getting a suntan I've got I'm online or I've got books
I'm reading all I can rule number two with Jocko willing make every second count
rome wasn't
built in a day
We all know that
Everyone's hears that
but rome also
Didn't fall apart overnight either
It took
Hundreds of years for Rome to reach its peak, but it also took time
hundreds of years for Rome to decay and fall apart
And that is representative of
Life because you don't achieve
Worthwhile goals quickly or easily they take time
They take struggle they take
Relentless pursuit day in and day out. That's what it takes
But also
things don't usually
fall apart quickly either
at least at first it's it's a slow process a
little slip here a
little setback over there a little
Wearing down of discipline and will over time
That's the thing success and failure are generally slow processes
Either slowly building things up or gradually tearing them down
And that's why I say you've got to pay attention
You have to watch you have to watch every single second because
Those seconds
They turn into minutes
Then minutes turn into hours and hours turn into days and days turn in to years
And so
That second
That second that just went by that
counted
And so did that second
And so did that one and in those precious seconds, you're either
building or
You're decaying you were either
Gaining ground or you were losing ground
In that second
And in every second
Every second counts
So
make every
Second count
Rule number three with David Goggins is be fueled by pain
So many people do we live in a very weakened society
so when they hear a throwback guy like me from back in the ancient days of
Garanimals
They often think this guy's just whatever. So if you think that I'm some unhappy guy you're wrong having lived a life
I've lived in
Seeing the other side not being afraid to attack
What was in front of me has made me happy to say that again. And in fact, let me make sure I understood it
getting to the point where you're not afraid to face the thing on the other side of the door that wants to attack you has
Made you happy right?
Right. It's really powerful. I hope people heard that right that made me very happy. So
Basically, I just don't walk around with a daggone smile on my face all the time. So, you know Merry Christmas
but but basically what the dark side is is
we all have a
cookie jar and
We all have a jar
That's its official name it's a jar of Man which just
it's just ain't going right and
In hell week what they do in hell week because this is where I really went to the dark side
we're doing hell week as they
design hell week to find your flaws and
They do a really good job of that. It's 130 hours of continuous training
You may get two hours of sleep and they beat this study. You will find everything
wrong with your mentality and then they start hell week and that's the beauty of it and
For me, I'm not some not no nasty guy giving guy, you know, I don't have a great bit of talent in anything
So what got me through horrible times was the dark side
Whereas I created my name is David Goggins. I
Created Goggins
Goggins is the guy that can take anything you put in front of them. You want to break my
So be it I have a way of going to a place I could did in that race
Where all the pain and suffering that they put on top of me in hell week?
I will reverse that pain and suffering and I will take your soul
So every instructor that put me through buds my job
What drove me?
Was I wanted you to go home that night after you beat the living shit out of me and I smiled in your face. I
Wanted you to feel worse than I did and you were going home to a nice warm bed
With your wife or your kids in a nice meal and I was still out there in the grip
Suffering for another 100 hours. I want you to think about me knowing that I'm comfortable being very
Uncomfortable and I want you to think about when you went to hell week. How uncomfortable you were and how bad you wanted to quit
Knowing I'm not thinking that way
So the dark side is something that I've designed
It's an evil place. I can go that
Very few things can hurt me. I
Used to hurt you're trying to put on me. I flip it upside down and use it. You can use it for kryptonite
now
It's power pillows for me. I'm using it for strength
I just flipped negative into positive Saudis rule number four with Gary Vaynerchuk is die on your own sword
It is far more fun to die on your sword than to die on someone else's I'm inspired YouTube
We're gonna make this the episode thing you'll get whatever you want Tyler, but this is the Corbett. You just saw it on stage
That's just you just saw it on stage
dying on your sword is better than dying on someone else's so many of you are doing things making decisions and
navigating your lives based on somebody else's thesis you're doing it because you think it's
The right thing because your dad's telling you it's the right thing you're doing what you're doing right now because you're pandering to your boss
Even though you don't believe in it. This is how it's gonna play out you are
Doing things right now yesterday you made a decision that you don't believe in
But you're smart you did because you know how your company scores here's the problem with disruption and innovation
Right. Now you're being rewarded for being a yes person and in 36 months
You're gonna be fired for being a yes person and you're doing it because you just need the security of your job
I'm telling you right now
If you're watching this vlog
And you've got like that means you have a certain DNA please I implore you please die on your sword
Not somebody else's if you're gonna lose it's much more fun to lose based on what you thought do
You know, I mean, do you know how many of you are gonna lose on?
Somebody else's thesis. It's gonna kill at you. It's gonna eat at you. It's going to be the worst feeling so please
Pause this video right now and ask yourself. Am I doing my shit because of me then you're good whether you're winning or losing or
am I doing it because somebody else is telling me it's the right way or I'm
Subconsciously pandering to please somebody or something because I need the short-term stability
Figured out the cow
You know it and I know it
You just need to do something about it and rule number fired
The last one before a very special bonus clip is with Tim Grover be fueled by failure
We're try so hard in our lives to fit in we try to fit into certain groups
Certain frats certain sororities, you know amongst certain friends yet
The people we idolize our most are the ones that stand out but when you're prepared there is no fear
There is no fear of failure
Okay
because even if you've walked out of something and you feel like you've failed at it your preparation is so strong that
You're gonna take that failure and turn it into the outcome you desire
And most people stop at failure. Okay, we've all failed at things. I'm gonna continue to fail at stuff like
It's the most powerful tool you can use
But it all depends on how you use it. You know, we talked about it in relentless. Okay a
scalpel
Okay in the hands of an individual it can do unbelievable damage
In the hands of a professional of a doctor it saves lives
So it's the same thing with failure. It's how you use it. It's that drive inside of you
Okay, it's what we talk about the dark side
The dark side is filled with failure, but it's the fuel that burns you like something that's never burned inside you before
Now I've got a really special
Bonus clip with Eric Thomas and how to not be average that I think you're really gonna enjoy but before that I want to know
Between these two which one is more important to you
Grinding or making every second count vote a for grinding B for making every second count
Let me hear thoughts down below. Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever. Your one word is much loved. I'll see you soon. And enjoy the bonus clip
Now listen what I want to talk to you night about is don't be average
Don't be average
Average people make a certain amount of money average people live a certain type of lifestyle and I'm not disrespecting average people
I'm just saying if you have a choice don't be average because in life when you roll the dice worst case scenario
You're gonna land on average, so don't be average because if you don't try you will get to average, right?
So let's not shoot for have it because average is gonna be there. So I need you to be what what's the P word?
I need to be what come on
I need you to be what?
And I don't need you to be nothing else when you do your job you do it in a way where note that you cannot
Get fired talking to my wife to dislike. I want you to clean up. I'm like we bout to get into it
I want to play I'm like how because I know you wanted a different way than how I do it. I clean havoc
I'm just being real I clean after so when you say clean you have to break that down because I know where my cleaning yo
Clean is two different claims
No, I'm trying to help you. It's two different clean. My wife said you don't clean you shift
So you take stuff from one area and you put another area that area clean with another area
When I clean you don't see nothing. Everything's gone some of you when you get a job you shift you don't clean
So I need you to find out what productive is when you get to that internship
You get that job you get in that relationship with that female that male whatever you do
I need you to find out what for done not what you think productive you find out what's really productive you do that and you
Ain't going they can't get rid of if you tell yourself a story long enough. You start to believe it, don't you?
Believe it, you act like I am Tulsa. What a whale out of handcuffs lightning throw thunder in jail
Now, you know, I'm bad on the last week. I murdered a rock into the stone
Hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make medicine sick
the fundamental
Key to success
is it can take between 18 and
250 four days of taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for confidence or every single day for 250 for days
I will be sending you a video
Between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long that you start your morning with around making you feel confident. It's
Absolutely. We check out the link in description below to get access